this week's episode is brought to you in
part by the American Dental Association
teeth tell a story we know what ancient
civilizations ate drink even where they
lived all from looking at their teeth
what story will your teeth tell about
you you're a DA dentists can help you
find out and give you the tools to keep
your teeth healthy for years to come
use the American Dental Association's
find a dentist tool to find the right
dentist for you go to ata org slash
science mag today this week's episode is
also brought to you by after the fact a
podcast from the Pew Charitable Trusts
30 years why does that number matter
it's been more than 30 years since a new
type of antibiotic has made it to market
now you might be wondering why a stat is
only the beginning of a story to
understand the number of shaping
society's biggest challenges listen to
after the fact a podcast from the Pew
Charitable Trusts available on stitcher
and anywhere else you get your podcasts
visit Pew trusts org slash science mag
to learn more
welcome to the science podcast for
February 1st 2019 I'm Sarah Crespi in
this week's show I talked with Borla
Smith editor of Science Translational
Medicine about clinical applications of
all this microbiome research that we've
been hearing so much about
and Megan Cantwell and Amita Sehgal
discuss a gene that induces sleep and
fruit flies that's also linked to
fighting off bacteria she's the editor
of the journal Science Translational
Medicine hi Orla hi there Sarah great to
be here you're celebrating your 10th
year of publication with a series of
essays they kind of look at different
areas of translational medicine and the
first is on the microbiome yes that's
right we actually launched in October
2009 so 2019 is our 10th year and we
have this focused series where we've
asked leading experts to write about
translational advances in their field
over the past decade
we're talking about the microbiome what
do you think has been the biggest change
in this area in terms of translational
medicine have there been leaps there
definitely have from 10 years ago when
it was very descriptive people were
we're using sequencing to sequence RNA
of all the microbial species in the gut
and then were able to say well the gut
microbiota is composed of these
different species so it was very
descriptive right and they were looking
at you know what happens in mice
sometimes when you introduce what is it
no bio it's nota biotic mice indeed
you're right those early experiments
were actually very clever because they
took fecal microbiota from humans and
put them into germ-free mice right he's
nota biotic mice and then they were able
to see what happened when they fed the
most different diets and that sort of
thing and so it was a very clever way to
be able to study the human gut
microbiota right in an animal model ten
years on how are we treating with her
involved like what kind of treatments
involve the gut microbiome so obviously
now what we're all really interested in
is how we can use what we've learned
about the gut microbiota that gut
microbiome to treat different diseases
so probably I think one of the biggest
leaps has been fecal microbiota trans
right and this is as it sounds taking
fecal matter from one human and
transplanting it into another apparently
according to the essay here it was
something that was first started in the
fourth century I believe it's been
around for a very long time now doctors
are doing it and what kind of things are
treated with us in people with a
horrible bacterial infection caused by
Clostridium difficile they become
completely debilitated but a fecal
microbiota transplant from what we call
a super pooper so these are people who
have very very rich fecal microbiota
material in fact this fecal microbiota
transplant can combat there prostrating
difficile and it's one of the few ways
that this bacteria can be vanquished
because it is multi drug-resistant so
it's resistant to even tough antibiotics
like vancomycin and someday we may be
banking our own fecal matter so if we do
get an infection we can just get our own
stuff back yes that's called an
autologous fecal microbiota transplant
and obviously does require that there
are banking facilities at clinical
centers but in fact there have been
papers and randomized controlled trials
where people have received their own
autologous fecal microbiota transplant
back after for example having a
bone-marrow transplant when they were
treated with very high levels of
antibiotics and so they've actually the
doctors have shown that people who get
their autologous fecal matter back are
able to replenish their gut microbiota
rapidly and it helps to improve their
survival rates another thing I learned
from this essay is that there are
prebiotics probiotics and host biotics
now I've heard of probiotics that's
where you're actually eating bacteria in
your yogurt or in a pill but what about
prebiotics and post biotics what are
those you're quite right about the
probiotics we you can buy them over off
the shelf in the supermarket and you get
them in yogurt of course in in fermented
cultures prebiotics are carbohydrates
that certain beneficial bacteria like to
eat it's actually like carbohydrates
supplement that can be added to food and
then the goal is that you you stimulate
growth of the good bacteria in your
and what about post biotics post biotics
are the metabolites the good metabolites
that certain good bacteria in your gut
produce long-chain fatty acids like
butyrate that have many beneficial
qualities so the idea of taking a post
biotic is that you just take the good
metabolites the long-chain fatty acids
without having to take the bacteria so
you're skipping the bug middleman you
are skipping the bug middleman and
you're treating yourself with whatever
the metabolites that would have helped
your health that was coming from
bacteria you're treating yourself with
that metabolites correct okay what kinds
of things are treated with pre pro or
post biotics I think it's still early
days for clinical treatments with pre
postman probiotics but as we learn to
understand more about bacterial
metabolism about what they produce about
how the bacteria in our guts actually
break down drugs or take a prodrug
and break it down to the active drug I
think we're going to see much more of an
influence of these pre post and
probiotics in medicine I see these
probiotics in the grocery store in my
yogurt or in a pill and I wonder what
kind of bacteria are they giving you how
do they know what kind of give you and
how effective are they at populating
your gut and helping you with your
health is that something that you can
answer or Allah or have somebody else
well I think everybody's were obviously
very interested about being able to pop
a plastic pill and become more healthy
at the moment we're still trying to work
out which of the good bugs and there are
certain that like the fit of actor and
lactobacillus or beneficial bugs that
are in many probiotics but one of the
issues is we have of course a very
populous gut microbiota and so it's not
clear how easy it is for them to take up
permanent residence whether there tend
to be more transients in which case
you'd probably have to take your your
probiotic every day or all your nice
breakfast cereal with yogurt in it I
want to move to the immune system this
has always been amazing to me this idea
that we have bacteria that were friends
with that our immune system recognizes
the way we recognize ourselves how have
we come to understand that relationship
better in the last 10 years so this is
one of the most exciting areas
I've got microbiota research because it
turns out that there is this amazing
synergy between our gut microbiota and
our immune system as you probably know
the gut has a very active immune system
and clusters of immune cells in the
peyer's patches so as it turns out
dendritic cells sample the gut
microbiota and then present those
microbial antigens to other immune cells
to induce tolerance so that we don't
attack our gut microbiota very cool and
is that something that people are
looking to influence for clinical
reasons very much so I mean obviously
there are autoimmune diseases and
inflammatory diseases like inflammatory
bowel disease such as Crohn's disease
and ulcerative colitis that involve a
dysbiosis in both the gut and the immune
system so this is still quite early
clinically speaking but they are looking
at ways to improve the gut microbiota or
modulate it to try and ameliorate the
symptoms of inflammatory bowel disease
great outside of the gut where else are
microbes important and are people
looking to them to you know help with
health yes that's a very good question
obviously most of the work has focused
on the gut because it's easy to obtain
fecal matter and no easy and run
sequencing and look a look at the
different microbial species and how the
composition changes with diet or with
health or with disease but we have
microbiota in many different tissues I
mean obviously in our in our mucous
membranes
you know nasal passages respiratory
tracts skin we have our own personal
host microbiota
there might even be different micro
biomes associated with different organs
yes
we're now beginning to understand that
each tissue may have its own microbiota
although again it's still very early
days and hot and hard to examine what do
you think the big hurdles are in this
field translating you know all this
research on the kinds of microbes where
they live how they change with disease
and health and obesity what's the big
hurdle to translating all this
descriptive research to the clinic and
to treating people so the real key will
be randomized controlled trials where
you can compare people getting
whatever it is right whatever microbiota
treatment it is versus people who are
not we are seeing the start of
randomized control trials and I think
the results of those are going to be
very very informative and are gonna
guide us moving forward one thing that I
noticed from looking across the
literature described in this is that
there's a lot of diversity out there is
that a problem with translating this
stuff into the clinic so you're
absolutely right that the gut microbiota
is heterogeneous it's it's different
from person to person people who are
different who live in different
geographical locale seek different diets
it really varies a lot and so that's one
of the big challenges about knowing
which specific microbial species are the
ones that will benefit all of us
so Orla what is on the horizon what's
really far out there when it comes to
translating microbiome research into the
clinic so I think there are certain
metabolic diseases obesity diabetes auto
immune disorders like the inflammatory
bowel diseases that could benefit
greatly from a better understanding of
our gut microbiota yeah I'm also really
interested to see how the microbiome of
the environment whether it's hospitals
schools or where we work interacts with
our own personal micro I think that's a
great question we recently published a
paper where the researchers looked at
the change in the microbiota in a
hospital from the day it opened when it
was brand new over the course of the
year with patients coming and going with
different illnesses and how doctors and
nurses and it's absolutely fascinating I
think we cannot ignore the microbiome
that's out there all around us so I
would say watch this space or Allah
thank you so much for talking with me
thank you so much it's it's really been
a great pleasure all right I really look
forward to the rest of this series or
Allah Smith is the editor for Science
Translational Medicine you can find a
link to the article we discussed at
science magcast stay tuned for Megan
Cantwell's interview with Amita Sehgal
about the link between immunity and
sleep
[Music]
when you're sick sometimes all you feel
like doing for the day is napping that
lethargic feeling is actually not
triggered by the infection you're
grappling with but your immune system
I'm here with Amita Sehgal to talk about
a gene that links sleep and immune
function
hey Amita hi first could you talk a
little bit about the processes that
regulate sleep the truth of the matter
is that we understand very little about
sleep we do know that it occurs with a
24-hour rhythm a circadian rhythm and
that's driven by a clock a biological
clock that's within us we know that
there's this other system called the
homeostatic system and the homeostatic
system is the system that ensures that
you get enough sleep usually the two
systems work together to determine when
sleep occurs but the homeostatic system
can sometimes override the circadian so
if you're up all night you'll sleep in
the morning even though your clock is
telling you to wake up we understand a
lot about the circadian process we
understand very little about the
homeostatic process like what is it that
makes us sleep even we've been awake for
a long period of time how did your team
approach isolating molecules that
modulate sleep and wakefulness we've
developed several years ago a fly model
for sleep and the reason we did that was
because we wanted to really get at
molecules and you know the genetics of
sleep which is harder to tackle in
mammalian models and the fly lends us up
beautifully to those types of approaches
where you can just mutagenize the animal
and then look for ones that have
aberrant sleep patterns
what was your study trying to figure out
that previous studies didn't address in
previous studies we had found genes that
affected sleep but for the most part we
found that those genes were required for
the animal to sleep with the want
drivers of sleep so you couldn't like
increase sleep above the normal sleep
amount so what we wanted was you know
what is the trigger like what is there a
gene that when you just increase it the
animal will become sleepy and that's
what we tried to do in this study right
in your team was successful in
identifying a single gene that induces
sleep called NIM Moody how are you able
to isolate this specific gene so we
basically took you know different genes
across the whole genome and overexpress
them like you know increased levels of
those in adult neurons and we find that
when we turn on this gene so that it
then makes makes protein the animal
sleep and no other gene from the 12,000
or so that we tested did that so what
normally triggers the expression of this
gene normally it turns out that when the
animal has very high need to sleep like
if the animal has been awake all night
or if the animal is sick during sickness
you know you'll need to sleep increases
cause sleep is restorative is the sleep
induced from this protein any longer
deeper or different than normal sleep it
is deeper and longer so what happens
when we increase expression of this
molecule duration of each episode is
increased saying they're sleeping more
but they're also sleeping in a better
consolidated fashion so each episode of
sleep is longer deeper sleep is actually
referring to the arouse ability so we
find that when you overexpress this
Molly if you increase levels of this
molecule that is harder to wake the
Flies up how exactly does this gene
promote sleep and fruit flies so this
particular protein it turns out to be an
immune molecule and it is produced in in
peripheral tissues right in the body and
it actually kills bacteria but normally
you don't even think of these proteins
as being in the brain although they are
and this particular molecule gets turned
on in the brain and it gets turned on in
the brain and very few cells like
probably just two cells and what it does
is act through the normal known sleep
circuitry as in the neurons that
normally affects sleep we don't know how
it does it but it seems to be connecting
to that sir
so in addition to the immune benefits
from inducing sleep it also has other
properties that help it boost the immune
system
it is also promoting immune function and
so we think that that when the animal is
sick it has a two-fold function on the
one hand it's killing the bugs on the
other hand it's increasing sleep both of
which are helping the animal recover
from the infection so it was the most
exciting part of this discovery to be
not the very fact that we could get a
molecule that would trigger sleep was
really exciting for us the fact that it
was secreted was also really exciting
because the sleep field has long
believed in the idea that there are
secreted molecules that can increase
sleep so many many years ago these
experiments were done where people
sleep-deprived sheep and goats and then
they took their cerebrospinal fluid and
put it into animals that had been
allowed to sleep and they injected
animals became sleepy they basically
were transmitting sleepiness from one
animal to the other by just taking
fluids secreted molecules have there
been any other genes discovered that are
similar to this gene you found in fruit
flies people have tried a lot over the
years to you know figure out what it is
that transmits that sleepiness from
animal to animal and it's unclear I mean
for awhile people thought that it might
be this molecule called adenosine which
is a breakdown product of energy
utilization but the effects of adenosine
on sleep already restricted to certain
parts of sleep and it's in certain areas
of the brain but importantly some of the
molecules that have been implicated our
immune molecules one of the reasons you
use fruit flies is because it's easier
to isolate the genes than in mammalian
models but what would be a potential
approach to figuring out if a gene like
this exists in humans there are similar
classes of molecules in mammals
antimicrobial peptides molecules that
kill bacteria so for starters what I
would do is work with them
or a rat model and inject them with
different antimicrobial peptides that
are normally made in those mice and rats
and see if they can induce sleepiness
thanks so much Amita Thank You Megan
Amita Sehgal is a muster professor of
neuroscience an investigator of the
Howard Hughes Medical Institute at the
University of Pennsylvania you can find
a link to her research at science mag
slash podcasts and that concludes this
edition of the science podcast if you
have any comments or suggestions for the
show write to us at science podcast at
AAA SOR G as a reminder we're looking
for a book reviewer so if you have
science and radio experience please do
get in touch you can subscribe to the
show anymore you get your podcast or you
can listen on the science website that
science mad org slash podcasts to place
an ad on the science podcast contact
mid-roll calm the show was produced by
Sarah Crespi and Megan Cantwell and
edited by Potter G Jeffrey Cooke compose
the music on behalf of science magazine
and it's publisher of triple a s thanks
for joining us